Gaspreis Deckel
von März 23 bis April 24 soll das gelten
ja also der Staat wird dann für einen
grundkontingent von 80% des geschätzten
vorjahresverbrauchs den Preis sozusagen
Deckel auf 12 Cent pro Kilowattstunde
das ist die Idee ja
ich habe privat also bei
privatverbrauchern und bei kleinen
mittelständischen Unternehmen genau das
ist die Idee so weil wir gerade hier
über über den politischen Streit
sprechen den sie sich da teilweise
liefern und mit so setzen die die
merkwürdig sind warum das fragt man sich
tatsächlich als Bürger dieses Landes
warum gehen sie nicht mal die wirklich
relevanten Dinge an an dem Punkt auch
zum Beispiel meine es wäre doch
gerechter wenn dieses grundkontingent
der Obergrenze hätte
das wäre gerechter
ich denke jetzt gerade an das
mittelständische Unternehmen was ja ein
Cap bekommt und ein Teil seiner seines
Geschäftsmodells kaputt nehmen vom
Privathaushalten man könnte man könnte
sagen was weiß ich da gibt es in
Obergrenze von 15.000 Kilowattstunden
zum Beispiel ja damit reiche Haushalte
mit hohem Verbrauch ich nicht zu sehr
davon profitieren
ich denke gerade an die fünf
sechsköpfige Familie in einem älteren
Wohnhaus im ländlichen Raum den hohen
Verbrauch hat und wir ziehen ein Cap ein
die haben mittleres Einkommen und stehen
da und fragen sich wie komme ich voran
bei dreifach vierfach höheren Gaspreisen
das wäre nicht fair das Beste wäre ihr
Schaffen gerechtig Rede von witzig
genau da will ich gerade drauf antworten
best case las King Ball hat es gerade
angedeutet wir haben
Einzelfallgerechtigkeit für über 40
Millionen Haushalten also jeder hat sein
perfektes Einzelmodell ich glaube dann
sitzen wir hier noch in drei Jahren über
und reden
Sie doch mal warum das ist doch
interessant das muss man den Leuten noch
mal erklären warum das eigentlich so ist
die Wahrheit ist das Versorgern schlicht
und ergreifend die Daten fehlen die
Einkommensdaten der privaten Haushalte
hinter dem Anschluss verbirgt ja ist
aber jetzt stellen wir uns eine Sekunde
vor die Energieversorger in Deutschland
hätten die einkommensverhältnis der
privaten Haushalte da muss ich aber als
datenschutzpartei sagen da hätte ich
große Bauchschmerzen mit wenn ein
Energieversorger über die
Einkommensverhältnisse und
Familienverhältnisse Bescheid wisst du
das wäre merkwürdig also da müssen wir
ein bisschen aufpassen ja ich sehe den
Punkt aber die Einzelfallgerechtigkeit
die in der Frage intoniert ist die würde
eine solche unfassbare Bürokratie
auslösen dass wenn die zu Potte kommen
bei der Digitalisierung stichst du unter
greifen nicht weiter
der Versorger beliefert einen zentralen
Abnehmer und hat keinen Schimmer wie
viele Haushalte und welcher Verbrauch
sich dahinter verbirgt kann Schimmer
nur der Energieversorger der einzelne
Gasversorger der hat natürlich der
schreibt ja Rechnung und der nimmt auch
ein Abschlag jeden Monat und er weiß
natürlich den Jahresverbrauch und weiß
auch um den Abschlag das weiß er schon
er weiß nur nicht um die
sozialverhältnisse dahinter und da hätte
ich jetzt auch offen gestanden
Bauchschmerzen das den Energieversorger
über zu überlassen diese Daten
Digitalisierung ich finde keine
Digitalisierung
und auch Digitalisierung am Ende worauf
ich hinaus will ist warum gehen wir
solche Projekte nicht mal an dass wir
einfach Dinge besser
lernst weil es gerade darum geht in
diesem Land Arbeitsplätze zu retten
dafür zu sorgen dass der soziale
Zusammenhalt gesichert wird dass diese
Gesellschaft nicht auseinander fliegt
ich das wird bei Christian dürr und bei
den fdp-kollegen nicht anders sein als
bei mir in der Fraktion das gerade
überall in den Wahlkreisen die
Mittelständler die industriebe auf der
Matte stehen und sagen bei diesen
Preisen die sich entwickelt haben in den
letzten Wochen werden wir hier nicht
mehr lange in Betrieb machen können bei
uns stehen die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
auf der Matte und sagen wir können diese
Abschläge nicht mehr bezahlen und da
müssen wir zahlen es ist gerade keine
Zeit für Grundsatz Debatten alles was
Digitalisierung angeht haben wir super
Sachen aufgeschrieben im
Koalitionsvertrag das werden wir auch
umsetzen aber jetzt gerade geht es darum
das Land durch diese Krise
durchzubringen und dafür zu sorgen dass
die Arbeitsplätze nicht nach China oder
in die USA verschwinden bin ich das halt
Grenzen dafür landet das Kabinett hat ja
gerade eine digitalstrategie besprochen
und beschlossen also das ist auf dem Weg
gar keine Frage und da ist viel liegen
geblieben also digitalpartei und
digitalpolitiker Mitglied einer
digitalpartei habe ich mich immer
darüber aufgeregt keine Frage das tun
wir das eine tun ohne das andere zu
lassen und ich sag mal ganz offen die
mittelständischen Bäckereibetriebe
zurzeit in Deutschland die haben richtig
Angst und dem ist meine Antwort geben
und diese ganzen diese Kommission hat
jetzt eine Antwort gegeben die ich für
richtig halte ich selbst komme aus einer
einzelhandelsfamilie meine Großmutter
war einzelhändlerin mit einer
Mitarbeiterin also kleine Betriebe über
die wir reden diese Millionen ein
mittelständisches Unternehmen die dürfen
wir dabei nicht vergessen und das
berücksichtigt dieser Vorschlag deswegen
sage ich gut dass wir die Kommission
eingesetzt haben gute Grundlage und
jetzt machen wir daraus Gesetze so Gas
ist das eine Strom ist das andere weil
wir gerade darüber Bäckereien und so
weiter sprechen
und in dieser Phase von der sie sagen da
geht es jetzt wirklich um industriellen
Kern dieses Landes liefern sie sich
einen kleinkarierten Streit um die Frage
ob zwei AKW ein bisschen laufen sollen
oder drei AKW deutlich länger was soll
das wenn Sie wenn die Frage kleinkariert
wäre dann wäre es ihr wahrscheinlich
schnell entschieden sondern es ist schon
der Streitigkeit
substanzielle Frage wo ich weiß dass die
Grünen fundamental sie kommen aus der
antih akw-bewegung eine andere
Auffassung aber ich will meinen
Vorschlag machen erlanz das was war
jetzt machen müssen ist doch in Wahrheit
All-In wir müssen alle Ressourcen nutzen
übrigens auch im Rahmen der europäischen
Solidarität gerade heute hat ja
Frankreich erklärt dass sie uns mit Gas
aushelfen werden umgekehrt sollten wir
einerseits alles tun so wie wäre es denn
wenn wir sagen wir lassen die
Kernkraftwerke länger laufen aber wenn
sie nicht benötigt werden wenn der Tag
gekommen ist ob das im März ist ich bin
glücklich wenn es so wäre oder im Jahr
2024 dann schalten wir sie wieder aus
meine Sorge ist wir dem zu viel Optionen
zur Zeit vom Tisch obwohl wir alle
Optionen brauchen weil wir wirklich ein
Energiekrise haben die Energiepolitik
der Vergangenheit in Deutschland war
aufgebaut auf erneuerbare plus Erdgas
und das Geschäftsmodell ist kaputt
gegangen mit diesem Krieg und das müssen
wir jetzt neu aufstellen und für den
Übergang des neu Aufstellens brauchen
wir alle Optionen das ist der Grund für
diese neuer Vorschlag den Sie jetzt
gerade sozialisiert in die Runde werfen
nein das ich will ich will weil sie
sagten kleinkariert nicht um
Kleinkariertheit oder oder dass sich
jemand in seine Wagenburg zurückzieht
sondern es geht darum jetzt in einer
Notsituation solche Entscheidungen zu
treffen und mir geht es nicht um eine
Renaissance der Kernspaltung in
Deutschland das ist politisch
entschieden worden sondern mir geht es
darum in dieser absoluten Krise alles zu
tun erstens und Blackout zu verhindern
und zweitens um die Preise stabil zu
halten und die Chefin der
gaspreiskommission über die wir gerade
Sprachen Frau Professor Grimm hat ja
genau den Vorschlag den ich gerade
gemacht hat auch gemacht und hat gesagt
wir sollten die Kraftwerke länger laufen
lassen damit der Preis 12 Prozent
weniger Prozent weniger Preis war schon
ein veritrapler Anteil wäre ja jetzt
noch mal die Frage
vielleicht erklären Sie mal wie sehen
sie auf diesen Streit wird gerade immer
wieder sozusagen die Notlage des Landes
beschworen diese dramatische Situation
und da haben wir diesen Streit den kein
Mensch mehr da draußen versteht ja ich
habe dafür auch nicht besonders viel
Verständnis und ich ich habe auch direkt
eine technische Nachfrage dazu es geht
ja um das dritte Atomkraftwerk in
Emsland und nach meinem Kenntnisstand
ist es so dass die Brennstäbe die man
dafür braucht dass sie alle schon
abgebrannt sind das heißt man bräuchte
neue Brennstäbe und das wiederum hätte
zur Folge dass dieses AKW mehrere Jahre
dann neu laufen muss und man kann diesen
diesen diese Aufweichung des Atom
Einstiegs finde ich jetzt auch nicht so
schnell herbeirreden dass es dann alle
Errungenschaften die die Anti
akaw-bewegung geschaffen hat dass das
alles wieder in Frage gestellt wird also
der Preis ist ein bisschen hoch mit dem
hier verhandelt wird und ich halte das
auch tatsächlich für unnötig und finde
ich angebracht in dieser Zeit dann kommt
noch dazu das auch in ihrer Partei Herr
dürr Christian Lindner zu Beginn der
Regierungszeit große Reden geschwungen
hat und davon geredet hatte es gehe um
freiheitsenergien für die die Liberalen
auch stünden und die
Atomkraftwerke zählte er ausdrücklich
nicht dazu also es ist jetzt nicht so
wie jetzt manchmal so ein bisschen
suggeriert wird als als wäre die FDP
schon immer pro AKB gewesen und das das
machen sie jetzt weiter sondern da gibt
es ja auch einige Gratwanderungen die in
ihrer Partei gerade passieren ich glaube
außerdem dass sie aus aufs falsche Pferd
setzen ich glaube nicht dass sie ihre
Stimmverluste dadurch wieder wett machen
können dass sie jetzt die akbs wieder
hochschreiben darf ich dazu zwei Dinge
sagen ganz kurz was die Motivlage
betrifft ist mir nicht darum
irgendwelche Geländegewinne oder sowas
sondern jetzt notfallentscheidung zu
treffen und zum zweiten haben sie was
ganz wichtiges angesprochen im
Wahlprogramm der FDP stand keine
Laufzeitverlängerung kein Wahlprogramm
einer deutschen Partei auch die Union
die das jetzt fordert Stanz nicht drin
sondern es sind notfallentscheidung und
da ein Bild gerade das Kernkraftwerk
Emsland zu sehen ist 200 Meter davon
entfernt ist das große Gaskraftwerk
meine Sorge ist dass wenn dieses
Kraftwerk im Emsland vom Netz geht dass
das 200 Meter entfernte
gaskraftventil Kernkraftwerk vom Netz
geht dass das Gaskraftwerk dann 24
Stunden laufen muss und wir noch mehr
gasverstrom müssen es sind also wirklich
Sorgen die uns umtreiben weil wir
zurzeit zu wenig Gas haben bitte das
nicht nur auf die politische Ebene heben
sondern der Notfallsituation geschuldet
okay
wie schauen Sie denn darauf was ist das
was da gerade passiert
also der Streit zwischen Finanzminister
im Wesentlichen und Wirtschaftsminister
der darum geht der Wirtschaftsminister
sagt was auf ich möchte gerne dass wir
diese zwei Kraftwerke im Süden länger
laufen lassen in den Frühjahr hinein ins
früher hinein und die FDP sagt also
Christian Lindner sagt wie machen wir so
nicht sondern wir hätten gerne drei
Kraftwerke und die lassen wir bis 24
laufen erstmal und dieser Streit
blockiert gerade die Entscheidung
darüber ob wir jetzt das durchziehen
oder nicht also ob wir weiter
gasverstrom erstmal bedauere ich
natürlich dass die Debatte darüber
gerade auch den Blick darauf
verhindert was alles schon geschafft
wurde weil wenn ich mal angucke wie voll
die gaspeicher sind das ist ein Erfolg
dieser Regierung wir bei lng-terminals
Vorankommen das ist eine Volk also es
gibt vieles wo wir Energiepolitik gerade
sehr sehr vieles richtig machen auch das
osterpaket das Sommerpaket also wirklich
der der wirklich dramatische Ausbau
erneuerbare Energien die mir gerade mit
der Regierung ermöglichen ich gucke auf
das Thema der Atomenergie sehr
pragmatisch und unidiologisch wir haben
Robert Habeck in der Regierung gebeten
dass er prüft ob wir eine Stromlücke
bekommen der Stress das ist zweimal
durchgeführt worden das Ergebnis war
eindeutig dass wir in Deutschland genug
Strom haben das ist sein kann dass
dadurch das in Frankreich die
Atomkraftwerke vom Netz sind wir
Christian dörrt gesagt europäische
Solidarität Frankreich helfen müssen und
ich sage in der Lanz meine Erwartung ist
dass die drei die das jetzt verhandeln
der Kanzler
Christian Lindner und Robert Habeck dass
die in dieser Woche drei Fragen
beantworten erstens hätte das eine
Auswirkung wenn wir die Atomkraftwerke
länger laufen lassen auf den Preis ist
der relevant da gibt es das was
Christian dür gerade gesagt hat Frau
Grimm die sagt das ist erheblich es gibt
andere Studien die sagen das ist nicht
so das zweite ist die Frage haben wir
eigentlich wirklich eine Stromlücke die
droht das muss beantwortet werden in der
Sache nicht ideologisch in der Sache
waren und das dritte ist auch ein ganz
wichtiger Punkt weil wir gerade über
Industrialisierung geredet haben mir
sagen viele aus der Wirtschaft aus der
Industrie wir brauchen eine Klarheit wie
die Energieform der Zukunft in diesem
Land aussieht ich glaube auch dass es
der Bereich der Erneuerbaren ist dass
man zum Beispiel Thema jetzt haben wir
die Notlage hier und die aber diese drei
Fragen müssen beantwortet werden und auf
dieser Grundlage muss dann in dieser
Woche entschieden so und da habe ich
jetzt eine Frage den Satz will ich noch
sagen können Sie das ist meine Erwartung
an die drei aber das öffentlich das
gerade diskutiert wird halte ich für
falsch und das
doch schon entschieden
kann mich ja keine
Regierungsentscheidung erinnern sie
hatten das entschieden
es war bereits entschieden es gibt einen
einen Schriftstück sogar dazu es gibt
darin den schönen Satz wir schaffen
außerdem die Möglichkeit die Süddeutsche
Atomkraftwerke bis zum Frühjahr 2023
laufen zu lassen
wenn ich das direkt sagen darf es gibt
die Pressekonferenz in der das
vorgestellt worden es ist ja der
Abwehrschirm den sie meinen die 200
Milliarden Euro und da kommt dieser Satz
drin vor Christian Lindner hat in der
Pressekonferenz sehr deutlich gesagt was
das heißt auch unwidersprochen hat
Robert Habeck das bestätigt
bleiben sie einmal da bleiben sie gerade
sagen Wasser gesagt hat ja wir haben es
vorliegen aber ich bin das einmal kurz
zu also sie gehen vor die Presse sie
treffen offensichtlich eine Verabredung
und irgendwie auch eine Entscheidung der
Kanzler der Finanzminister der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister dann findet
sich darin dieser Satz noch mal wir
schaffen die Möglichkeit die
süddeutschen AKW bis zum Frühjahr 2023
laufen zu lassen und dann passiert etwas
vor den Augen der Staunen Öffentlichkeit
dass ich beim besten Willen nicht
verstehen kann auch als Bürger dieses
Landes und man fassungslos dann
vorstellt das gleich gerne noch mal ein
genau bei Christian Lindner der das hier
mitgeschrieben hat und damit offenbar
einverstanden war in dieser
Pressekonferenz bei der Vorstellung des
Satzes das direkt wieder so halb
einkassiert wir schauen mal ganz kurz
rein
wir nutzen für die Zeit der Krise hinter
diesem Abwehrschirm die Kohle bis 2024
wir haben auch jetzt beschrieben in dem
Papier was der Status Quo bei der
Kernenergie ist also zwei Süddeutsche
Kraftwerke auch im Frühjahr 2023 zu
verwenden das ist noch Gegenstand auch
der weiteren Beratung und
Meinungsbildung ist das worauf wir jetzt
schon bauen können sagt ganz offen ich
bin der Überzeugung wir brauchen alle
Kernkraftwerke auch bis 2024 das hat
sich auch nicht verändert
warum macht man das so das verstehe ich
nicht das hat er genau hinter der Tür
vorher gesagt natürlich hatte ich aber
nicht das ist das ist die Bereitschaft
die Robert Habeck zu dem Zeitpunkt zu
gehen weil wir hatten uns vor ein paar
Monaten noch eine andere Situation da
war der Wirtschaftsminister der fest
Überzeugung auch das muss sich damals
akzeptieren dass wir gar nichts brauchen
das alle zum 31.12 vom Netz gehen können
jetzt haben wir die Situation dass er
sagt wir brauchen Sie mindestens bis
März ich sage es ist sicherer genau wie
kriegst du nicht mehr als beschrieben
hat gerade lieber alle Optionen auf dem
Tisch zu lassen wenn die Option nicht
benötigt werden bin ich sofort parallel
nehmen politische Kommunikation aber
fragen tun wir gerade alles als
Politiker um eine Krise abzuwenden dann
schreiben Sie mir nicht so auf
der Status Quo das ist das was Christian
Lindner gerade zitierte war zu dem
Zeitpunkt dass das was Robert Habeck
bereit war zu gehen ich glaube er sollte
mehr gehen und ich bin total bei Glas
klingen bei das müssen wir jetzt klären
aber die Haltung die ich dazu habe Herr
Lanz die darf ich doch erklären warum
Gottes Willen also ich will ja erklären
warum wir sagen lieber all in lieber
alle das schon jetzt nutzen als
verstehen
beim ersten Entlastungspaket gemacht
haben wir waren ja gemeinsam
Koalitionsausschuss beim zweiten beim
dritten das Ergebnis dieser Pakete war
dass wir mit dem 200 Milliarden Euro
Schirm das größte Paket in Europa haben
dass wir die besten Maßnahmen bei diesem
Thema an dem Schritt auch noch zum
Ergebnis kommen noch mal sie gehen nach
vorne es wirkt auf die Leute da draußen
als hätten sie sagten gerade die
Wirtschaft braucht Sicherheit es wird so
als hätten sie jetzt Sicherheit da gibt
es diesen Satz schriftlich kann jeder
nachlesen und auf der anschließenden
Pressekonferenz wird direkt wieder so
halbeinkassiert wie finden wir das
jetzt haben sie mir gerade versucht zu
unterstellen dass ich Robert Habeck
kritisiert hätte wenn ich jetzt bei
Lindner noch nach lege dann machen Sie
ruhig nee das sie haben doch auch habe
ich nicht kritisiert haben
meine Anforderungen an die drei die das
gerade verhandeln formuliert ich will
dass das in dieser Woche abgeräumt hat
ich will diese Woche Klarheit die
brauchen wir es muss geklärt werden weil
es gerade wichtige Themen in diesem Land
gibt und das liegt gerade da drüber das
nicht gerade keine gute Kommunikation
sie sind gerade politikstratege des
Jahres geworden das ist doch deswegen
formuliere ich ja mein Anspruch das ist
in dieser Woche geklärt wird und den
zweiten und dritten Satz den können Sie
sich jetzt denken den ich dazu sagen
könnte das ist mir den sage ich aber
nicht ich erwarte dass diese Woche
abgeholt wird okay sie finden es richtig
doof ich erwarte dass diese Woche ist
doof das ist ihre Interpretation
zu interpretieren
also ich meine wenn Sie es ernst meinen
und ich unterstelle den jetzt mal das
jetzt ernst meinen dass sie diese Krise
abwenden wollen dann müssen Sie sich
doch auf konzentrieren dass diese
Koalition gut arbeitet und sie wissen
also Herr dürr sie wissen ja ganz genau
was sie den Grünen abverlangen und wie
stark das mit der parteipolitischen
Identität verknüpft ist und die haben
schon solche Gratwanderung vollzogen in
den letzten Monaten wenn sie jetzt auch
noch ihre anti-akkw-haltung aufgeben was
bleibt denn da noch von den Grünen und
das wissen Sie ja ganz genau insofern
finde ich das verantwortungslos zu
diesem Zeitpunkt diesen Streit zu führen
und dass das jetzt vollkommen unabhängig
vom Ausgang der Landtagswahl in
Niedersachsen gewesen sein soll das
glaube ich einfach auch nicht das ist
dann schon auch strategisch platziert um
sich sichtbar zu machen ich meine an der
falschen Stelle von dieser Spaltung die
wir jetzt gerade erleben profitiert
genau einer die mir Putin also es wird
weder die SPD davon profitieren noch die
FDP noch die Grünen es wird hier Putin
davon profitieren und es wird die AFD
davon profitieren also insofern in so
einer Lage solche Inszenierungen
das muss ich widersprechen weil ich es
ausdrücklich nicht für ein Inszenierung
halte sondern ich halte es für eine
notwendige technische Entscheidung im
ökonomisch auf einem Level zu bleiben
damit wir damit eins nicht passiert ich
glaube unsere geopolitische Stärke
gegenüber putin ist auch unsere
ökonomische die spielen wir gerade
richtigerweise aus da sitzt ein Despot
im Kreml der versucht die liberale
Demokratie anzugreifen und zwar nicht
nur in der Ukraine da kostet das
furchtbarer Weise Menschenleben
deswegen sehen sie mit meinem Motive ich
möchte dass wir diese ökonomische
Grundlage behalten in Deutschland damit
wir gegen jemanden die Putin ankommen
sie sind ja auch ökonomer was man merkt
auch heute Abend da geht nichts mehr
gerade nichts
und dann muss am Ende Greta Thunberg
herhalten ich habe jetzt gar nicht
zitiert macht das Christian Lindner der
Bundesfinanzminister vielleicht können
wir das mal kurz zeigen der dieser Tage
twitterte ich begrüßte den Zuspruch von
Greta Thunberg für die FDP-Position
unsere Kraftwerke am Netz zu lassen
unsere Kernkraftwerke am Netz zu lassen
das ist
sag mal bemerkenswert muss man ganz
vorsichtig zu sagen sie kennen noch
seine alte Einlassung zu dem Thema zum
Thema Kernenergie seine ja die alte
Einlassung dazu zum Thema Kernen zum
Thema Greta Thunberg also er hat zum
Thema Fridays for Futures einiges
gemacht wir können das mal lösen schauen
Sie mal hier dass das ist die alte
Einlassung ich finde politisches
Engagement von Schülern toll von Kindern
und Jugendlichen kann man aber nicht
erwarten dass sie bereits alle globalen
Zusammenhänge das technisch sinnvolle
und das ökonomischen Machbare sehen eine
Sache für Profis und ich will ergänzen
das Jahr also damals
2019 steht da steht da drunter
ja nun in vielen Interviews glaube ich
eingeordnet noch mal ich finde es
interessant dass Greta Thunberg diese
Haltung hat aber ich hatte sie offen
gestanden schon bevor geräter Thunberg
das gesagt hat oder vor einem
Wahlsonntag okay deswegen sehen Sie mir
nach dass ich eine Haltung habe die ich
an empfehle in so einer schwierigen
Situation trotzdem kommen wir zusammen
am Ende aber das ist Politik und
Demokratien Leben auch davon dass es ein
Diskurs gibt und ich glaube man kann
heute Abend den Eindruck gewinnen dass
wir ganz vernünftig miteinander umgehen
eigentlich ich glaube die schaffen das
auch ohne Greta tunberg jetzt zu lösen
der hat das hätte ich irgendwie ganz gut
aber es ist wirklich
bemerkenswert die dann plötzlich jemand
den man vor drei Jahren irgendwie noch
für jemanden hielt der von nichts eine
Ahnung hat plötzlich als Kronzeugen
sozusagen auf Schild hebt doch hat er
nicht gesagt er doch im ersten Tweet aus
2019 gar nicht auf Kreta Thunberg das
ganze bezogen geschenkt was müssen denn
die Grünen der FDP bieten damit sie auf
die Geschichte verzichten auf das dritte
AKW und auf die längere Laufzeit ich
glaube ich muss meine Antwort von vorn
wiederholenden Lanz dass es mir
aufgestanden zu spielerisch für den
Ernst der Lage was muss wer wem bieten
das ist ja fast wie beim Monopoly das
finden also ich finde die Diskussion
darüber absurd es geht doch nicht darum
ein Politiker glücklich Entschuldigung
sondern die richtigen Entscheidungen zu
treffen sie haben selber vor zwei Wochen
gesagt die gaspreisbremse muss daher in
Funktion mit der Laufzeitverlängerung
der Kernkraftwerke kommen ja weil ich es
für sehr sinnvoll halte wenn wir eine
gaspreisbremse einziehen und ich hatte
vorhin erwähnt der nebenstandort neben
dem Kernkraftwerk Emsland ist eben ein
Gaskraftwerk wo ich die große Sorge habe
dass dann sehr viel verstromt würde das
heißt die Gasnachfrage steigt wir haben
vor die übereinsparpotentiale und
Notwendigkeiten schon gesprochen und das
dann das ganze den Preis nach oben
bringt und am Gasmarkt an anderer Stelle
wieder was für die Dinge hängen leider
zusammen ist so Welt ist komplex
die Zusammenhänge muss man erstens
erkennen und in dem Zusammenhang in der
richtige Entscheidung treffen deswegen
macht es aus meiner Sicht als Ökonom
auch Sinn eine Preisbremse mit einer
Mengenausweitung zu verbinden denn wenn
man die preisdeckelt und die Menge
gleichzeitig knapp hält dann ist das
Delta das was der Staat hier unter
Umständen reinstecken muss immer größer
und das möchte ich möglichst vermeiden
dass sie zum Schluss bevor wir gleich in
den Iran gehen den Blick noch einmal
kurz ein bisschen weiten weil sie Ökonom
sind und weil sie auch häufig über
wirtschaftliche Zusammenhänge sprechen
und die Frage aber Anlass Klingbeil wie
groß ist eigentlich ihre Sorge man sieht
wie sich das hier so blockiert was da
gerade passiert ist wir uns streiten
zwei Kraftwerke drei Kraftwerke mit
Blick auf das was zum Beispiel die
amerikanerkarte machen meine die
Benchmark sind die Amerikaner was doch
gerade stattfindet ist eigentlich auch
im Hintergrund an unglaublicher
Handelskrieg das ist doch das was
stattfindet die Amerikaner
subventionieren ihre Wirtschaft mit
gigantischen Summen es gibt die ersten
Unternehmen die bereits in die USA gehen
dort für ein Zehntel der Energiekosten
die hierzulande da sind produzieren und
wenn wir nicht runterkommen auf ungefähr
Stefan weil dieser Tage darüber
gesprochen 7 Cent ungefähr für die
Kilowattstunde für die Industrie haben
ein echtes Problem
ja die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit müssen wir
erhalten im Interesse der Arbeitsplätze
aber das Wohlstands insgesamt wir sind
ja das kommt hinzu auch Dinge die wir in
der Ampel beeilen Bearbeiten einer älter
werdende Gesellschaft demografischer
Wandel also Wohlstand zu erhalten das
ist wirklich unfassbar wichtig und da
spielt Energie eine ganz große Rolle
deswegen empfehle ich uns da breiter zu
denken jetzt mal abseits der konkreten
Entscheidung die hier zu treffen ist
darüber nachzudenken dass wir über
energy nicht nur reden über über die
Frage von Wasserstoff nicht nur reden
sondern wir führen zum Beispiel auf
europäischer Ebene gerade die Diskussion
was es mit e-fuels also synthetische
Kraftstoffe CO2-neutral breiter denken
wir werden in Deutschland davon bin ich
überzeugt in Zukunft auch über
Kernfusionen reden also was ich damit
sagen will technologieoffen bleiben
heißt diesen Wettbewerb ich haltest dich
für ein Handelskrieg sondern für ein
ökonomischen Wettbewerb mit den USA den
zu gewinnen und eine Empfehlung würde
ich uns nicht geben lieber viele
Optionen haben erfolgreiche
Volkswirtschaft zu sein als ökonomischen
Schaden zu haben und dann die Hoffnung
zu haben dass der Staat das mit
Steuergeld ausgleicht das ja der zweite
Weg den man gehen könnte es ist ein
Schaden entstanden und jetzt muss der
Status ausgleichen das wird uns nicht zu
mehr Wohlstand bringen und die kann man
brauchen wir gar nicht über den großen
Teich gehen die
Briten haben es gerade versucht die
haben ja auch so ein großes Programm
versucht auf dem Weg zu bringen mit dem
Effekt dass das Pfund abgerauscht ist
die ihre Anleihen nicht mehr platzieren
können und da kommt die Rolle die Frau
Bethke eingangs vielleicht auch der FDP
in dieser Koalition zugeschrieben habe
dass wir davor waren das ist ökonomisch
nicht schief läuft und dass die
Staatsfinanzen nicht in eine schwierige
Situation
ich wollte nur sozusagen die kleine
Frage noch einflechten
wenn man das sieht was da passiert wenn
man sieht was auch in England ist ein
gutes Beispiel was da gerade passiert
ist also wenn man sich irgendwann
verhebt schlicht und ergreifend und dann
in so eine Situation kommt und Dinge
unwiederbringlich kaputt gehen und damit
auch Millionen Arbeitsplätze so da muss
man doch erst recht sagen
okay wir machen jetzt alles was geht und
wir diskutieren auch nicht ideologisch
wochenlang rum richtig und also ich bin
nicht bei dem Griff Handelskrieg weil
ich auch sein benutze nicht ich dann
benutzen Leute die sich mit sowas auch
ich bin da nicht weil ich auch gerade
sehe wie wir in der frage-ukraine
beispielsweise mit den Amerikanern ein
wirklich engen draht- und Austausch an
das transatlantische Spieler
gemacht profitieren gerade massiv von
seiner Situation in der wir auch
energiepolitisch durch Fehler der
Vergangenheit sind davon profitieren die
Amerikaner massiv so und die sieben Cent
sind übrigens auch Teil der der
gaskommission also auch der
Industriepreis 7 Cent weil es da ja ohne
Mehrwertsteuer ist deswegen ist der bei
7 Cent nicht bei 12 aber das ist auch
drin die Industrievertreter Michael
Jades andere waren ja auch mit in der
der Kommission drin aber das wird der
Industrie helfen hier Fuß weiter halten
zu können und hier zu bleiben und hier
auch die Arbeitsplätze zu erhalten aber
sie haben Recht damit und das ist auch
das wo ich dann genervt bin dass wir
wegkommen müssen von dem kleinen kleinen
der letzten Wochen wir haben eine große
Aufgabe gerade als Ampel zu erledigen
und die haben wir eigentlich sogar in
einem Koalitionsvertrag ohne dass wir
diese Krise schon kannten die jetzt
konkret mit dem Krieg auf uns zugekommen
ist ich meine ich war einer von drei
Generalsekretären der diesen
Koalitionsvertrag ja mit organisiert hat
das war ein Aufbruch der da war und
jetzt sind wir ein Jahr später in einem
totalen Durcheinander in der Regierung
und ich erwarte dass alle sich da am
Riemen reißen dass der Ruck jetzt auf
sich der Berliner Politik geht weil die
Aufgabe die wir haben die
Industriearbeitsplätze hier zu halten
den sozialen Zusammenhalt zu sichern die
Modernisierung des Landes voranzubringen
das ist uneingeschränkt und durch diesen
Krieg und durch die Energiekrise sogar
noch dringlicher geworden aber diese
Verantwortung tragen wir alle und daran
wird diese Regierung am Ende auch
gemessen ob wir das geschafft haben ob
wenn jetzt alle davon ausgehen dass die
Krise bis Mitte 2024 dauert ob wir dann
noch hier industrielle Wertschöpfung
haben oder ab Wertschöpfungsketten dann
so kaputt sind dass sie nach China oder
in die USA gewandert sind daran werden
wir gemessen